when you go to the beach and you look at
the ocean it oftentimes might look
fine but as we'll see in this video we
human beings have been stressing aquatic
environments and if we're not careful
we might completely ruin them for
example
this is what a healthy coral reef looks
like
and coral are fascinating organisms
you can view them as little animals that
are fixed in place
because they're releasing this calcium
carbonate
the same things that eggshells are made
of that they're fixed to
and then that builds the coral reef but
they can exist
they have their homeostasis in a
particular temperature range
and a given amount of various chemicals
that are in the water
now we know that human beings were
causing the climate to warm
and that's also causing ocean
temperatures to warm
and as ocean temperatures warm many of
our coral reefs
are not able to be as sustainable
for example this is a less healthy coral
reef
some of the coral is still alive and
seemingly doing okay
but in other places you see what is
known as bleaching
where the reef is now white and that's
because in those situations
the coral is essentially dying off now
you might say well this is unfortunate
because coral reefs are very beautiful
and now it is less beautiful but what
are the other impacts
well all sorts of organisms and animals
live in coral reefs
get their food from it get their shelter
from it and if the coral reefs start to
die off then the animals are going to
die off
on top of that these coral reefs that
the coral are essentially
building as they live they prevent
erosion
on the coastlines so one change that
affects one organism or one part of an
ecosystem
can have a lot of follow-on effects on
other parts
of the ecosystem another perhaps more
obvious way
that we've been not being nice to
aquatic environments
is things like oil spills and you've
probably seen this on the news when you
have major oil spills they tend to be
pretty disturbing images
but this right here is a bird that is
covered in oil and you can imagine when
a bird is covered in oil
it's not going to be able to fly it's
not going to be able to swim
it's not going to be able to have food
and in a lot of cases it is likely to
die
and just as we described with the coral
reef this doesn't just affect the bird
it affects the entire ecosystem
including human beings and this is just
the effect on a bird
it has effects on fish it has effects on
the just natural
balance that occurs in that aquatic
environment
now another idea that is less talked
about
is this notion of oceanic dead zones
and this right over here is a picture of
the gulf coast right off the coast of
louisiana i was actually born
right around there and what it shows
is every year this hypoxic zone which is
a
zone of low oxygen levels in the water
form
off the coast and this shows how bad it
is the red areas are the really bad
very low oxygen sometimes you might
forget you might say okay
for all of us who live in the land or
live on the land or in the air we
breathe oxygen
but organisms in the water need oxygen
as well oxygen that has been dissolved
in the water
and what's interesting is why this forms
it's actually a little bit
counter-intuitive
it turns out that chemicals from human
runoff especially fertilizer so you can
you might not realize it but this is the
delta of the mississippi river
and that has runoff farm runoff from as
far north as minnesota and chicago and
sewage
and that farm runoff and that fertilizer
and that sewage
as it comes into the gulf it actually
promotes
algae formation and you might say oh
that's good some more life is growing
but so much algae gets formed and when
that algae finally dies
and it gets decomposed the decomposers
actually use the oxygen remember when
you are actually trying to
metabolize things you're using oxygen in
order to extract
that energy and so the oxygen in the
ocean in that area gets depleted
and then you have a situation where
almost nothing
can live in these zones right over here
and this is just a sample of the things
that we are doing to our aquatic
environment
and there's other things there's
elemental sources of mercury that we
throw into aquatic environments and it
makes the water highly toxic
there's obviously other forms of trash
pollution that we put into the water but
this is just to give you a sense and to
start giving an appreciation
about how imbalanced everything is and
how in one part of the country
say in chicago waste that's going into
the mississippi river
can affect aquatic environments
thousands of miles away